I'm so mean he is mean
okay I am so sorry you went through that
Rihanna coming to Super Bowl champ
Patrick mahomes's defense after a little
prank ahead of the big game I can do
whatever I want it went down last week
when former NFL player Brandon Marshall
told the Kansas City QB during a press
conference that Riri is his biggest fan
Rihanna came out and said that you are
the greatest quarterback ever yeah
Mahomes was totally Starstruck over the
compliment crush it a half
a half we're excited about the halftime
show than they are the game and so
whatever Rihanna says is like like the
gospel so I'm glad that she she went
with me for that for that honor but
after that heartfelt response Marshall
set the record straight she didn't she
didn't
but on the bright side Mahomes can count
rimry on his side Marshall came clean to
the singer after the prank and clearly
the QB can stand under her umbrella any
day that's so mean he is mean okay I am
so sorry you went through that
I still think you're great he's a hater
though
[Laughter]
that whole prank thing happened just
days before ree's big return to the
stage after seven years
[Music]
you want to get it right you know
everybody's watching
and they're rooting for you yeah and I
want I want to get it right challenge
that I was willing to accept well being
a new mom nothing would have gotten me
out the house if it wasn't a challenge
like that yeah she definitely got it
right Not only was it an unforgettable
perform
three also made history by revealing
she's expecting baby number two gently
cradling her bump during songs like
diamonds
it really feels Like A lot's happening
all at once it feels like motherhood
Oscars Super Bowl I'm still pinching
myself really I'm grateful I'm grateful
and while fans thought Rihanna might
bring out some surprise guests she opted
to make it a solo act
still gonna run this town tonight
[Applause]
I think it was just
her wanting to make the statement that
she could carry this thing and she did
and people would just want to see her
and so she had to give him a show and
she did choreography we haven't seen her
dance like that in a long time and I
thought it was just spectacular the
Super Bowl is one of the biggest stages
in the world yeah it's an Entertainer's
dream to be on a stage like that
extra
[Music]